so the Teen Titans is the best thing
come at a DC rebirth right now this this
comic is amazing now here's the funny
thing
admittedly I never watch Teen Titans
when I was growing up but I'm Teen
Titans came on I was out of that phase
of my life I was at a point where I was
going to parties and stuff like that
what you guys watched as Teen Titans
when you were younger like that was my
x-men the animated series let me tell
you something man action in the animated
series back in the knife Japan limited
Azon back in the 1990s that's that show
stands the test of time I know there are
a lot of you guys out there right now
who were just like Teen Titans is the
best show ever but we did not come here
to talk about x-men the animated series
and relive nostalgia we came here to
talk about the Teen Titans so here's the
cool thing about this this team Titans
roster as we see it is not an action I
mean it's not like DC was like well
we've always had the Teen Titans you
know for like 70 years like we should
have the Teen Titans again I mean you
know we there's always been an iteration
of them yes there's always been an
iteration of a Teen Titans ever since
they were first introduced back then you
know before crisis on Infinite Earths in
the post-crisis landscape there's always
been a team Titans team some iteration
of them the New Teen Titans the new 52
Teen Titans as much as everybody hated
them there's always been different
iterations of the team but this version
is actually as close as we get to the
show the only people who are really
lacking here is Robin you know Tim Drake
I think it was inside with everybody
else is virtually the same while flash
wasn't on that version of the team but
it's kind of a kind of a measure of
familiarity it's really kind of blending
what people recognized with what also
makes sense I mean if you were watching
Teen Titans when you were younger and
you sit down me read this book you like
well I mean cyborgs not there you know
and Tim Drake's not there but that makes
sense because Tim Drake is off being his
own hero and cyborg is you know being a
security guard for the Justice League so
it makes sense that we would see you
know that we receive those characters
off doing their own things the idea here
is that in truth there is no younger
version of cyborg there's no kid cyborg
but we do have a kid flash at the same
time the Teen Titans comic also serves
as a place to flesh out characters who
kind of need to be fleshed out with the
return of the classic Wally West to DC
rebirth what this is done is its shine
the new 52 Wally West in a new life
because now it's given fans choice when
the new 52 first kicked off classic
Wally West fans were pissed because
there was no classic Wally West but now
there is the classic Wally West and
there's the new 52 Wally West then fans
now have a choice and so they're a
little more accommodating a little more
welcoming to you know this new person -
Kid Flash
because
now they get to kind of focus on him and
get the character they wanted so there's
a little more breathing room here and
there Teen Titans offers the opportunity
to flesh out these characters plus it's
just cool to see Starfire you know and
you know Beast Boy and all that kind of
stuff you know even I'll just kind of
gather together on a single team but the
cool thing about this is remember when
we did our Teen Titans rebirth video
they'd all been kidnapped and brought
together by Damian Wayne and this is
actually really kind of cool here
because initially the response of all of
them is just like we don't know why
you're here
but we're going to break ourselves out
and we're going to defeat you and we're
going to we're going to gain our own
freedom now this is initially what
Damian Wayne was shooting for because
what he says is you guys are all free
now like individually you guys can
easily be defeated but together you're a
cohesive unit you are a team now this is
DC really kind of making a market
difference between Damian Wayne the way
he used to be and the way that he is and
that's really the crux of this whole
story it's kind of like you know the
continued evolution of Damian Wayne and
it makes sense because if you look at
his life as a character it's always gone
in stages in terms of how DC you know
had his character you know how they how
they designed him he was originally the
heir to the League of Assassins you know
he was going to be this insane assassin
guy who was going to train as part of
the league eventually he was rolled over
into Batman son of the bat he was
trained under Batman and he was given
guidance and he was given to religion
terms of removing him from this realm of
just killing every villain he finds and
understanding that you just can't go
around killing people there's always a
better way to handle things
this continued evolution puts them on a
team and it says okay let's pair Damian
Wayne up with people around his same age
and let's see how he copes with this
let's see how he does as a role of a
leader Plus Robins always been a leader
of the Teen Titans so it just makes good
sense but that's kind of cool because he
says this is the New Teen Titans now
again the other half of this is the
Damian Wayne is very much like Batman I
mean look you know well know like hey
look go grab your own friends you know
we don't want to have anything to do
with this Damian's response is that he
doesn't have friends but he doesn't tell
them everything either he doesn't tell
them everything that's going on he
doesn't say here's everything that's
happening he keeps a lot of things very
close to the vest he keeps it very
hush-hush and so ultimately what it
reveals it so the reason why he formed
this team is because of the fact that if
he doesn't do that they're all going to
die now the reason for this really seems
me because of the fact that Ra's al Ghul
has his own group called the demons pit
which is just this group of child
assassins and we'll learn more about
them in terms of what they representing
I'm not really being introduced and so
on but again you know
whole idea of keeping things very quiet
of keeping things very much to himself
comes in the form of the fact the Teen
Titans don't trust it you know they
don't see him as somebody they can kind
of confide in and that's really the
cornerstone of any particular team the
cornerstone of the team is that you have
to trust the person next to you you know
presumably with everything that you have
if that doesn't happen you'll never be
successful now of course in this
scenario they're kind of forced together
as a team by circumstance when the demon
fist goes to attack them all at the same
time of course the way this happened was
that where the demon fist was originally
assigned to track down Damian Wayne
because Damian had gone around and
basically kidnapped the various members
of the of the Teen Titans a tracking
device is basically placed on Kip flash
which led the demons fess to the
location of where they are now but each
member of the demons fist is capable in
their own right I mean you have play who
basically can cause illness among people
you've got shapeshifters people who are
super strong people who deal with magic
you've all you got all different facets
of you know abilities that are invoked
here and what this does is it basically
it's designed to complement each
individual member of the Teen Titans
none of the sense that they're going to
work together as a team but in this room
so they can all kind of pair off into
their own individual groups and face off
against one another now the antithesis
to Damian Wayne is a girl named Mara and
will actually learn a little bit more
about our character here in a little bit
but the idea here is that where this
initial trust begins to become somewhat
of an issue in the sense that at this
point it's really all this kind of
fending for themselves and fighting as a
team out of circumstance where Damian
Wayne basically bails out and then
returns with a jet and rescues the rest
of the team Titans this begins to go
into the realm of them basically
shedding aside this sort of gar this is
kind of wall they've created around
themselves letting their guard down and
kind of exposing who they are to all the
other members of the team now of course
kind of transitioning back in the past
for a little bit this is again I'm not a
little bit of introduction with regards
to the past of Damian Wayne and what we
learn is that as you know the heir to
the League of Assassins Damian Wayne was
tasked with initially leading the demons
fist but his conflict with Mara comes in
the fact that the two of them were
really kind of vying for this position
Damian Wayne demonstrating that he was
the superior fighter but this was also
at a time when he would read basically
lost his humanity he was a killer first
and he was what passes for a human
second and the result is that in the
scenario where he and Mara were fighting
kids temporarily let his guard down she
tried to kill him with a dagger he threw
her back and scar her and so what this
did is it basically left her with this
just kind of you know physical
station of this internal hatred that she
had for Damian Wayne which has guided
her every you know every sleeping
nightmare and every waking dream ever
since she's been around so because of
this with this little segment of the
characters basically coming together
what essentially happens here is they
begin I just really DC begins to
juxtapose these two individuals next to
each other now really in a lot of ways
Damian just kind of recounts his history
to Dee to the to the Teen Titans and
essentially saying look you know I was
the son of the demon you know I was
basically a guy I was a kid who was
trained to be a killer I was trained to
be an assassin
I was traded to I was trying to lead the
demons fist but when given the
opportunity to choose between the life
you know a life is part of the League of
Assassins and a life is part of Batman I
chose Batman and what this did is it
allowed Mara to basically take my place
as the head of the demons fist which in
turn basically put Ra's al Ghul in a
position where he had to seek me out and
he had to take me down but the other
half of this is they all basically begin
to go through and kind of reveal their
own issues their own struggles you know
with regards to let's her Raven you know
what she talks about are these things
that she scares herself as much as she
scares others because graven is still in
a lot of ways learning what she's
capable of not only that in some
instances if people seize control of her
if they twist her mind inside out she'll
lose control of everything know her
whole relationship with trigons all
these different aspects of her character
terrify her in a lot of ways but terrify
others as well and because of that they
basically made her an outlier when it
comes to Kid Flash new fidgety Wally
West is terrified of his path he's
terrified that he's going to become a
bad guy each one of these own individual
characters have their own struggles they
have their own issues and this is the
core of what the Teen Titans were about
right I mean when the Teen Titans first
showed up it was a like teenagers
reading comic books wouldn't you love to
be Batman wouldn't you love to the
Aquaman and wouldn't you like to be
Superman well you can't but you can be
the flash and you can be Superboy and
you can be Aqualad Feeny was cool you
know to see those things unfold and
teenagers identified with those
characters but the longer the Teen
Titans went on the more became a
necessity to develop their characters if
for no other reason than to just
continue telling compelling stories and
so because of that we started getting
stories like Marv Wolfman New Teen
Titans which focused on the
interpersonal relationships between the
characters different members of the Teen
Titans falling in and out of love but
the idea was that the team Titans always
reflected teenagers they always
reflected the life of teenagers those of
you guys who were young you're falling
in love you're
out of love your bodies are changing
you're learning your place you're going
through these existential crises we
don't know who you are or where you're
going or what you're about but you're
trying to figure it all out it's one of
these great things about all these
characters about the Teen Titans in
terms of how they relate to teenagers in
general now of course all this really
comes to a head when we basically learn
that at the same time we're the Teen
Titans are opening up to one another
where they're becoming more of a team
even if they're not really intending to
the demon Fisk is the other way around
they're a team only in so far they've
been brought together by Ra's al Ghul
but there's no trust there they don't
like each other they're not a team
they're just a group of people working
towards a common goal and what it really
comes down to it the bonds of fellowship
that are formed between the members of
the Teen Titans are what keep them
together in comparison to these members
of the demon fist who don't have those
bonds and so when it comes to the point
where you begin breaking them down on
personal levels there's no bonds to tie
them together there's no shoulder to cry
on there's no one to pick them up when
they fall they're just left there and
they're replaced with something better
should one of them fail it's the nature
of the League of Assassins but it's
arguably the failure of the League of
Assassins the biggest failing that it
has now of course this eventually leads
to Damian Wayne basically turning
himself over to Ra's al Ghul in exchange
for sparing the Teen Titans and that
really kind of brings to a head this
massive transition of Damian Wayne
because when we think back to when his
character was first introduced he never
would have done this you know if Ra's al
Ghul had said your job is to go kill the
Teen Titans they would have been dead
and that would have been all there was
to it there have been no debate no
argument no nothing Damian Wayne would
have shown up on their doorstep he would
have calculated the best way to take
every last one of them out and then
there would be no more Teen Titans they
would all be dead but in this instance
Damian Wayne is willing to sacrifice his
life in order to make sure that the Teen
Titans
stay safe now the way this happens isn't
the fact that he's going to be executed
it's trial by combat it's the crux of
the entire function of the League of
Assassins but the reason why this
happens is because of the fact that when
Ra's al Ghul brings Damian Wayne towards
via you know to the mirror of truth
which reveals their deepest darkest
desires when he ends up doing is he sees
Damian Wayne and says when I see you I
see you as the next Ra's al Ghul when
you see yourself you see yourself as the
next Batman and so what this means is
that Damian Wayne is effectively beyond
this realm of going back to being part
of the League of Assassins is DC
effectively confirming he's crossed that
line that he cannot and doesn't want to
come
back from he doesn't want to go back
across that line he doesn't want to go
back to being part of the League of
Assassins he just want to go back to
being the heir to Ra's al Ghul he wants
to stay where he is now and become
Batman that's the whole role of his
character and you know in DC rebirth
it's him constantly coming along
challenging Dick Grayson challenging
Bruce Wayne say I should be the heir to
the Batman mantle one because I'm the
most capable of all the Robins at least
he believes he is and two because he's
like I'm the biological son of Batman it
makes sense then I would be the one who
would take over the role of that man and
so again this particular trial by combat
leads him into a direct conflict with
Mara herself now of course the funny
thing about this is that in the initial
conflict Damian just totally I mean is
he's easily able to overpower her it
doesn't really even last very long it's
basically disarming her you know
challenging her threatening to kill her
and match that but in this instance of
turning his back he essentially makes
the same mistake that he did last time
the difference here is that instead of
being on his guard he lets his guard
down he boasts he brags he allows his
arrogance to get the better of him now
here's the funny thing about this this
is not a result of him training with
Batman it's not like well yeah you know
training with Batman has made him weak
not at all because you could easily
imagine that in this scenario Batman
would have just kind of you know he
would have facepalm and just like why
were you not expecting that like you
should have expected something like that
to happen you know this girl is a win by
any means necessary kind of person you
should have expected something along
these lines and so because of this but a
Teen Titans you know with Beast Boy
having you know basically been a fly and
overheard Damian Wayne basically giving
himself up to Ra's al Ghul and then
reporting back to the Teen Titans but
heightens basically jump in and they
effectively rescue their friend and
that's the coolest thing now because
what it means is that the Teen Titans
now see themselves as a cohesive group
they see themselves as people that can
function together as an actual entity
now of course this eventually leads into
a direct battle between you know that
the demon fist and the Teen Titans
themselves but what Damian Wayne does is
he drops his massive bombshell you know
what he tells the the members of the
demon fist is that they weren't given up
either parents you know they weren't
basically warrants that were adopted by
Ra's al Ghul they were taken from their
parents they were effectively kidnapped
brainwashed and trained into becoming
assassins now the reason why this
matters is because the members of the
demon fist had grown up believing that
they were outcasts that the League of
Assassins was the only home they had
because their parents didn't want the
Harmonists information brought to them
basically reveals their
inner true nature innocence they don't
really want to be here they don't really
want to be members of the demon fist
they've accepted that because they
believe that to be their life but Damian
Wayne is showing them a glimpse of a
better life he's shown them that there's
light at the end of the tunnel the grass
is actually greener on the other side
and so because of that these members of
the demon fist effectively turncoat they
immediately turn against you know Ra's
al Ghul and say we're done here we are
no longer going to have any part in this
nonsense you know that you're that
you're running about you know that
you're you're causing and creating and
so on and so forth so again what this
does is it leads to Ra's al Ghul you
know kind of fending off as less he can
I've been eventually grabbing Mara and
kind of taking off but at that point it
allows the members of the demon fist to
kind of go about and find their own way
and this is really cool because this is
something that I hope you notice with DC
Reaper with DC Reapers a lot of groups
are either being brought back or being
introduced for the first time DC is
bolstering their numbers they're
introducing the demon fist Batman has
his own Justice League of America we've
now got the multiversal Justice League
that came out of the Superman story the
numbers are being bolstered the numbers
are being increased all of this is
presumably going towards the direction
of this massive battle between the
Watchmen and the Justice League that
seems to be what's happening there's all
these numbers all these groups are being
added all these numbers are being
bolstered all these things are happening
that seems to effectively be the case
now of course once this was all said and
done
Batman kind of shows up at the Damian
Wayne and he's like so what are you even
doing man uh I see you stole my jet it's
kind of fun I mean it's one of these
funny little things because it's kind of
interesting to see the Teen Titans in
relation to Batman because they're just
like dude that's bad man dude it's kind
of funny because again what this does is
it shows us how the members of the
Justice League are viewed by the Teen
Titans in the sense that they're just
kind of like I mean like that's - that's
him like the Batman man like it's crazy
because the Teen Titans view themselves
as a team but it's also just like it's
almost like one of those things where
you could imagine the Teen Titans kind
of being like average people right like
they see the Justice League flying
through the sky and some jet you know
Batman being carried by Wonder Woman or
something along those lines they look up
and all they can do is just say wow you
know and that's what it's like with the
Teen Titans they see Batman it's just
like wow
- this Batman
man it's crazy you know and it's just
kind of funny to see them enamored to
see them intrigued to see them kind of
swept up in the moment now of course
they end up kind of having to take off
you know and let you know Damian and
Batman sort of get together but what
this also does is it sets the stage for
Damian branching off and doing his own
thing it sets the stage for Damian
branching off and saying look you know
I've spent enough time under the mantle
of Robin you know as part of the Batman
landscape it's time for me to go out and
make my own way in the world now one of
the other reasons why this happens is
because as part of the League of
Assassins culture 13 years old is when
you become a man and so in the eyes of
Damian Wayne and really even in the eyes
of Bruce Wayne Damian is a man now what
he's doing with regard to the Teen
Titans is the equivalent of you going
out into the world earning your own
wages getting your own apartment and
starting your own life what is up
happening is the Teen Titans basically
formed their own little Titans Tower out
in San Francisco and it basically sets
the stage for the Teen Titans group to
come together and possibly even recruit
more which of course we know that
they'll add another member to their
ranks all of which is going towards the
idea of the whole Judas contract
storyline but again if you guys are new
here to come and explain make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the rock or if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later
[Music]